now we're moving into the world of
native apps and this is a world that's
flourishing you might notice some
similarities between what we spoke about
for the web but there are also some
specific monetization methods for native
apps at first you need to think what
would be the best model for your app
it's likely to change but that's fine
you need to be agile and listen to your
customers let's look at some of the most
popular options first you can monetize
premium apps that's selling your app for
a fixed price in a lot of cases this
might not provide you with enough
revenue so you can also optionally
include ads or use in-app billing to
sell additional features or content now
this model works great for certain
categories like games for kids in this
example parents can pay a full price up
front and a model with like ads or
in-app purchases may not work as well
since the kid would have to make those
purchases however this model may also
limit your apps monetization potential
in developing markets you may be able to
achieve greater revenue using the
freemium subscription or advertising
model and monetizing freemium apps users
are more likely to download the free app
later you could use several options to
monetize first use in-app payments to
unlock more features for example games
like Angry Birds clash of clients and
many others in productivity apps
Evernote spring note all are using this
to provide a free tier second
subscriptions for recurring services it
might be used progressively or expired
after a period of time such as a game
booster or a new subscription many
examples like Pandora Financial Times
strava Dropbox and many more are using
it another option is just to leave the
app free and use it as a marketing or as
an announcement to another product
ecommerce is another monetization option
in this model you can sell physical
goods like tomatoes clothing electronics
what have you and you can also sell
other services think about Etsy and
Amazon as good examples of e-commerce
the question is which model
the best results for your app most add
services are made to help you figure out
what combination work best both for your
audience and your bottom line you should
remember that you will need a lot of
traffic in order to make this model work
for you